los bloqueos se mantienen en la frontera
con estados unidos país al que canadá
envía al 75 por ciento de sus
exportaciones
tras 11 días de protestas en contra de
las restricciones por la pandemia en la
capital ottawa los camioneros del
llamado convoy de la libertad ahora
restringen el flujo en el puente de
ambassador que une a michigan con un
tario por donde circulan unos 8000
camiones al día los camioneros han dicho
que no se irán hasta que se levanten
todos los mandatos de las vacunas pero
también piden la renuncia del primer
ministro josh incluido quien hoy pidió
el fin de los bloqueos los canadienses
tienen derecho a protestar a no estar de
acuerdo con su gobierno y hacer oír su
voz siempre protegeremos ese derecho
pero seamos claros no tienen derecho a
bloquear nuestra economía ni nuestra
democracia ni la vida cotidiana de
nuestros ciudadanos eso tiene que
terminar como medidas para reprimir la
protesta la policía de la capital ha
incautado miles de litros de combustible
y ha retirado un camión cisterna y el
parlamento de canadá se reunió de
emergencia el lunes para debatir sobre
la crisis que ha dejado a ottawa en
estado de emergencia y que algunos han
llegado a calificar como una humillación
ningún oficial está en días libres todo
el mundo está trabajando estamos al
límite pero estamos comprometidos al
cien por cien a utilizar todo lo que
tenemos para acabar con esta
manifestación una cadena de suministros
organizada ha sostenido a los
manifestantes durante todos estos días
pero las autoridades anunciaron el
cierre de las cuentas de la plataforma
code farm que financiaba a los
manifestantes